there are several factors that can
affect the rate of a reaction one factor
is the concentration of a reactant
most chemical reactions proceed faster
when the concentration of one of the
reactants is increased for example let's
look at the reaction of solid zinc with
hydrochloric acid to form an aqueous
solution of zinc chloride and hydrogen
gas
let's say we put a piece of zinc metal
so i'll go ahead and draw in the piece
of zinc metal in here in a flask that
contains three molar hydrochloric acid
so in our flask here we have three molar
a solution of three molar hydrochloric
acid
as the reaction proceeds hydrogen gas is
formed so we could monitor the rate of
this reaction by observing
the amount of hydrogen gas bubbles that
are coming out of the flask
let's say that we repeat the experiment
this time instead of using three molar
hydrochloric acid we're going to use six
molar hydrochloric acid so we've
increased
the concentration
of our hydrochloric acid solution
this time when we add our piece of solid
zinc to our six molar hydrochloric acid
solution we would observe more hydrogen
gas bubbles coming out of our flask
so we have increased the concentration
of one of our reactants hydrochloric
acid and we've observed an increase in
the rate of the reaction
as the concentration of hydrochloric
acid increases there are more acid
particles to collide with the piece of
zinc and therefore as the concentration
of hydrochloric acid goes up the
frequency of collisions increase and the
rate of the reaction increases let's use
the same reaction to talk about another
factor that affects the rate of reaction
and that factor is surface area
we've already reacted a piece of solid
zinc with hydrochloric acid we could use
three molar hydrochloric acid again and
we saw some bubbles come off of the
piece of zinc indicating that hydrogen
gas was produced this time let's try
breaking the piece of zinc into smaller
pieces so instead of using one large
piece of zinc here we have a bunch of
small pieces of zinc and if we were to
do the experiment again with three molar
hydrochloric acid this time we would see
more
bubbles of hydrogen gas coming off of
those small pieces of zinc
so we have increased the surface area
of the solid and we observed an increase
in the rate of the reaction
when we had only one piece of zinc the
rate of the reaction was limited by the
surface area of this one piece therefore
by breaking it up into smaller pieces we
were able to increase the rate of the
reaction
temperature is another factor that can
affect the rate of a reaction so let's
say on the left we have
a glow stick in a flask that contains
some cold water
and the glow stick let's say the glow
stick is already glowing here so let's
draw in this color here for our glow
stick
the glow from a glow stick comes from a
chemical reaction and if we were to
increase the temperature so let's say we
we heated this flask on the left so we
increase the temperature we would
observe the glow to get stronger so
let's go ahead and draw in here a more a
more vibrant glow coming from our glow
stick so increasing the temperature must
have increased the rate of the reaction
the reason increasing the temperature
increases the rate of the reaction in
general is because increase in
temperature means the molecules are
moving faster and therefore the
molecules are colliding with each other
with greater frequency and with greater
force which increases the rate of the
reaction
a catalyst is another factor that can
affect the rate of a reaction let's look
at the balanced equation for the
decomposition of hydrogen peroxide which
turns into water and oxygen and let's
say in our flask on the left we have a
solution of hydrogen peroxide the
hydrogen peroxide is decomposing at room
temperature but the reaction proceeds so
slowly that we don't see it even
happening
we can speed up the reaction by adding a
catalyst let's say we have an aqueous
solution of potassium iodide
in our beaker here and we pour the
solution of potassium iodide into
our flask containing the hydrogen
peroxide
the addition of the iodide ion as a
catalyst causes the decomposition of
hydrogen peroxide to occur very quickly
and we would see a huge plume of gas
come out of the reaction flask so the
addition of a catalyst in this case it
was the iodide anion
increased the rate of the reaction
a catalyst increases the rate of
reaction by affecting the kinds of
collisions that occur between particles
and a catalyst increases the rate of
reaction without being used up